The craziest person in my family is...
I'd definitely say my mom.
Mom could go into a mental institution.
She should be in white, padded walls at all times.
Wait, let's start over.
Most secretive?
The most secretive person in my family is probably...
I'm pretty shady.
Yeah, Khloe.
The bravest person in my family is...
I think Kim is pretty brave.
Kim.
The things Kim does are wild.
After you've become a mom, you're very fearful.
I'm not fearless like I used to be.
The bravest? Me.
We're both really brave.
We are, we have the Jenner in us. We're both pretty brave.
Much braver than the Kardashians.
The funniest person in the family is Khloe.
Funniest has to be Khloe.
I think Kourtney is the funniest.
I agree, but Khloe is the second funniest.